I know you've been acting since you were
4 or 5 years old haven't even this is
your first big featured film and the
lead role now what I want to ask you is
so this is a horror movie but you'd
never actually seen any horror films
before this idea at all no I literally
had never watched a horrible couldn't
even make it through the sixth sense
about crying and so when I got it all
gave me five DVDs of pretty much the
worst like the scariest horror movies
around and over Christmas me and my
family sat and watched them and stuff
like martyrs and frontiers and really
brilliantly made films were obviously
really scary and I've become quite
addicted to what I really like scary
films now but as working one was
incredible getting to kind of see how
it's all done the prosthetics and the
blood and yeah it was really billion did
you feel it's been worth having that
horror education oh completely yeah
really really really great they what
kind of feel to be looking out for notes
in your horror liner and gosh I'm not
sure I'm seeing a couple here at pride
fest I'm seeing VHS the possession and
tower block do you have no lines and a
film as you play a young deaf mute girl
don't you and but obviously that doesn't
mean that the part is easy because you
have to communicate lots without speech
how did you find that it was a challenge
what I kind of atactic I came up with
was if angel could speak I'd have the
line that she would be saying in my head
and so that way it would kind of come
across on my face but and me and Paul
sat down every morning and worked out
kind of where angels emotional state was
every in every scene that we were going
to be shooting so that was really
helpful to me you have a difficult not
to react when the noise is onset when
you are acting all the time I think it
became Paul's catchphrase of Rosie your
death you can't hear that and because
obviously no matter what you do you
can't actually kind of become deaf so it
did take a lot of focus and especially
those like loud bindings coming
and you learned sign language know some
sign language in it you did you work
with deaf kids before yeah I've worked
with deaf kids and I kind of seen how
they reacted to stuff so I knew it I
knew a little bit of sign language but
the sign language we do in the film is a
different kind of sign language and so I
got to work with a really amazing person
who taught me how to store the sign
language so how did you find that really
good it was really torn the unfortunate
I can only remember about one sentence
out the entire film I can remember one
sentence but yeah at the time it was
really really great and I think
Dominique who plays Vanya is way better
at it than me but I had fun doing it
it's really as well as emotionally
demanding role really physically
demanding world isn't it how do you cope
with something like that and it was
difficult I have lots of scars on my
legs from the from the stunts but it was
Britain I love doing hormone I did
pretty much all my own stunts part from
one and and that was really great and I
think every night I just would go home
and kind of sleep a lot and then get up
and do it but it was the best experience
of my life so within pretty intense
listened to I mean what were the best
sense or the scariest answer you had to
do scare it the fight there's the
massive fight scene which was
interesting cause a lot of coreg
fishermen when that was really good but
the funnest was I fall off out of a
window and so I was on a harness and I
get to drop about 20 feet and yeah
that's really cool and did you get
thrown into a pit full of maggots or
some next a pit full of dead bodies and
a maggots face-first and pulled the
director he has a saying that he would
never make one of his actors do
something that he wouldn't do except
maggots Paul was terrified of maggots
and so he made but he made me fall
face-first into maggots
that's fine but they're fine so it was
really good tell me about building a
rapport with Kevin who plays your captor
in the film was a kind of a easy thing
to do yeah Kevin's such an awesome guy
and we
and sat down and we'll talk about
Ireland before we started filming and so
yeah we all we shot every scene we were
doing we'd have like a little rehearsal
and work out what each of our characters
were doing yeah so it was really easy
and fill me on location as well also
like showed old or ES pace weren't you
outside London we were actually in they
built that they had the seasoning house
and so there are times where I did
actually feel like like I was kind of
living in this very amazingly built dark
dingy place but an incredible set and it
was such a team effort on this film and
to everybody became like a family so
when it was over it was really sad to go
back to school talking about family your
family's here tonight aren't they to see
the film for the first time yeah I hope
they like it there they don't they
haven't seen any of it so fingers
crossed that they like it what's next
for you Rosie and I've just finished
three months filming in Manchester a new
ITV series come home front which is on
itv1 this autumn
you